what kind of a night have you had then a
fantastic night
um groundbreaking resorts for the
liberal Democrats across the country
exceeding the expectations of all the
independent pundits before I came on air
we just heard that we've gained control
of the Royal Borough of Windsor and
maidenhead from the conservatives a
fabulous result and there's worse yet to
come for the conservatives the hands of
the liberal Democrats so just start
Accounting in Surrey Sussex and
Hertfordshire and Oxfordshire so in
those traditional conservative
heartlands what I've called the blue
wall seats the Democrats are making big
gains and in our traditional homelands
in places like Dorset and Devon I think
will make big gains as well so yes it's
been a brilliant night for the liberal
Democrats and I think our positive
agendas really helped liberal Democrats
traditionally do you do well in local
elections don't they so can you draw any
conclusions about how your party might
fare in a general election from these
results so far well if you look over the
last 30 40 years liberal Democrat MPS
have been elected on the back of really
good local government elections so um
we're really proud of our local
government colleagues and their
campaigns but it really sets up as
really well for the next general
election I think there'll be a lot of
conservative MPS in those blue wall
seats in Evan and Dawson Somerset and
other areas who are now really worried
about the liberal Democrat Challenge and
I'm I'm really positive about the
policies our policy has been really
popular on the doorsteps on the NHS
people are really blaming the
conservatives for the ambulance delays
the difficulty getting a GP appointment
or an NHS dentist and they like what
little Democrats have been saying on
that well labor also are taking
advantage of what you say is people
turning against the conservatives
they've had a good election so far
however it would take a huge swing for
them to win a majority at the next
election if they did turn out to be the
next big party we're back in Coalition
Coalition territory aren't we because
I'm focus on beating those conservative
peas and India SMP MPS in Scotland where
I think the liberal Democrats have
really good chance and you know I I'm
increasingly confident about our ability
to be conservative MPS of the next
general election and I don't think the
conservatives can be removed from
government if liberal Democrats don't
beat those conservative MPS so I I'll
just say to your viewers if you live in
those blue wall seats in traditional
liberal Democrat heartlands where we are
the challenges to the liberal Democrats
and that's now in many many seats please
come and join us to beat those
conservative MPS but you're dodging the
issue of Coalition is that something
that you would consider I I'm not
dodging I'm just saying that our focus
at the moment is to remove conservative
because I couldn't be clearer about that
um I I thought the conservatives all my
life I I think they've really let down
our country particularly on the NHS the
other thing that people seeing the
doorstep which maybe hasn't had the
coverage it deserves but this is what
voters have been saying they feel that
it's not just their chaotic incompetence
but it's they lack integrity
think all those lies and dishonesty
we've had from the conservatives in the
last few years that's now people have
seen through them and they now say we we
don't want this this anymore and I think
they want to change you've had a fair
amount of success in by-elections in the
last year that's been put down uh as a
rejection of Boris Johnson are you
worried that with Rishi Cena coming in
it's going to be a very different
Prospect look at the results tonight
absolutely not you know uh in wind and
redhead come back to that no one
expected to take those results and I
think you will find by when all the
results are counter number Democrats
have made really really good gains and
Rishi sunak and the conservatives will
be very worried you know on the doorstep
people weren't really almost bothered
who was the Tory prime minister it was
the Tory party that they feel is divided
chaotic and the other thing that people
kept saying to me is they feel the
concert is out of touch they don't get
real people they don't care and and I
think I think that's really true if you
watch them in Parliament and what I'm
determined uh for my party the liberal
Democrats is to speak to voters concerns
and focus on things like the Health
Service things like the cost of living
things like the environment we've LED
for example the campaign against the
water companies pumping their filthy
sewage into our rivers and seas but
consultant MPS have been defending that
and yet a lot can change between now and
a general election probably next year
not least the issue of the cost of
living inflation set to come down people
may feel that the government is fixing
things by the time of the next general
election prices won't come down
the inflation of the conservatives has
been Dreadful and the inflation rate
might come down because that's how the
economy can can work at times with
global issues happening but inflation
has been really bad in our country take
food food prices are rising fast in this
country than almost any other of the
major industrialized countries and it's
the food price that they're hitting so
many families and pensioners on top of
the energy bills and the headline rate
of inflation come down but people still
feel really let down and feel really
worse off under the conservatives
conservative made our country poorer but
rich is so not a tougher opponent than
Liz truss or Boris Johnson for you well
at least trust was never very long so
it's very difficult to analyze but she
was a shockingly poor prime minister I
mean Richie suno was by the side of
Boris Johnson he was Boris Johnson's
Chancellor
so all the economic mistakes that
happened at a Johnson are now under
sunak Richardson needs to take take the
blame out and I I think he can't escape
that he can't escape the blame and nor
can the conservative party they are out
of touch they've let people down and
what I'm concerned about is making sure
people see the liberal Democrats as a
party who can be conservatives and on
the results of last night which were you
know off the scale for us really
fantastic I think people are turning to
us